attaboy don't be killer good in bed
citronella netting DEET all the things
we use to arm ourselves against a pesky
foe the mosquito there are over 3,000
species of these arthropods in the world
if you're in North America you can be
bitten by 175 different types these
blood-sucking pests carry diseases such
as malaria and the West Nile virus and
they cause an average of 2 million
deaths around the world each year our
attempts at curbing the population of
mosquitoes has so far failed one of the
reasons that this disease-carrying bug
is so dangerous is because of its size
we usually don't know when a mosquito is
biting us and even if we do it's too
late
but what if mosquitoes were as large as
humans how dangerous would they be and
is it even possible for a mosquito to
survive at that size this is what if and
here's what would happen if mosquitoes
were the size of humans
[Music]
like vampires mosquitoes are known for
blood sucking but they don't do it for
nourishment like many other bugs
mosquitoes need sugar from nectar to
survive
so why do they suck animal blood
well female mosquitoes need a particular
protein and lipid only found in animal
blood in order for them to lay eggs a
standard mosquito weighs just two and a
half milligrams but they need a sizable
1 milligram of blood just to produce 40
eggs and they can lay up to 300 eggs
during their average lifespan of 2 to 6
weeks this is why only female mosquitoes
bite and draw blood so what would happen
if they were the size of humans
well for starters transmitting diseases
would be the last thing you'd worry
about if a female mosquito were 79
kilograms and still required almost
three times her body weight in blood
over her lifecycle then she would need
237 kilograms of animal blood to lay
those 300 eggs in other words she would
need to suck every last drop of blood
from your body and from 236 other people
- yikes at the very least it could
become difficult for female mosquitoes
to get enough blood to lay her maximum
amount of eggs so the population might
begin to decrease quickly and we
probably want to kill as many as
possible maybe scientists would develop
some sort of pesticide that only harmed
mosquitoes and not humans or maybe
they'd become another big game target to
hunt down it's also possible that
predators would begin to eat mosquito
eggs and larvae further curbing the
population a mosquito has an exoskeleton
meaning it has to molt as it grows this
period of transition would be a
vulnerable time and could make killing
them
much easier human-sized mosquitoes would
be bad news and not just because they
could easily kill us they would likely
target cattle horses and large wild
mammals creating chaos in both the meat
industry and in nature but would a
mosquito even be able to survive at 79
kilograms in our current atmosphere
probably not arthropods breathe through
openings called spiracles that connect
to a branching network of trachea this
network of tubes diffuses oxygen
throughout their body and because of
this system the amount of oxygen in the
air limits their growth during the
Carboniferous period the oxygen in
Earth's atmosphere was almost 35% at
that time arthropods were huge but today
the oxygen in our atmosphere is only 21%
that's not enough for a human sized
mosquito even if it was mosquitoes would
need to develop a much stronger
exoskeleton to support all that extra
weight and because they need more nectar
to sustain themselves many would likely
starve we might not see human sized
mosquitoes anytime soon but we could see
a rise in giant mosquitoes called gala
nippers these mosquitoes are 20 times
larger than their cousins and are native
to North America they're so large
they're able to bite through clothing
since mosquitoes are cold-blooded they
need temperatures over 26 degrees and
with global temperatures on the rise
gala nippers could easily expand their
range and population another possibility
is that the growth of mosquitoes could
also spur the growth of their natural
predators
just imagine giant spiders roaming the
earth but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]